[Music]
hi I'm Jana an engineer at Google
working on Google cloud platform and
open source integrations and I'm patty
an engineer at a Shi Corp on the
terraform team terraform is a tool that
lets you provision your infrastructure
on any cloud or even across multiple
clouds in a safe easy to manage way in
the last two videos you saw demos of
vagrant development environments with
Google compute engine and Packer for
producing compute engine images we're
going to pick up where we left off last
time with using Packer to create a
compute engine image with our ad style
arcade game hyperspace pre-installed and
ready to go continuing our story our
game is near completion and now we're
getting ready for our big launch but
because we know our game is going to be
viral we want to make sure that we can
handle the load so rather than run
hyperspace on a single compute instance
and hope that it can handle thousands of
players we're going to take advantage of
the architecture and create one image
with a front-end web server and a
separate image with the back-end server
and all I had to do for that was make
some customizations to my hyperspace
install scripts and use Packer to create
two images instead of the single on one
image you saw in the last video so now
that we have a scalable way to package
hyperspace let's talk about how we can
deploy it to Google cloud platform
paddy any idea how we should go about
that actually Dana I think I know just
the thing today we're going to use
another hashey core tool called
terraform to help us deploy hyperspace
with this new split front-end and
back-end approach terraform is a tool
that allows you to write declarative
configuration file describing the state
of your infrastructure it allows you to
provision resources such as VMS disks
networking configurations and databases
and it works with many cloud providers
including Google cloud platform but you
already knew that right Dana now you
could say I'm pretty familiar with
terraform I'm the lead engineer at
Google working on our terraform
integration with Google cloud platform
we've heard from plenty of our customers
that they really like using terraform to
manage TCP and appreciate that everyone
has support for multiple cloud providers
with terraform users can manage TCP
resources spanning many of our products
such as compute engine cloud storage I
am cloud sequel cloud DNS etc but for
this demo we're going to focus on
compute engine
so let's get started the first thing you
want to do is go to terraform bio and
download the software for your platform
refer back to the vagrant and Packer
videos for setting up your DCP project
for this demo we're going to use
terraform from an existing Google
compute engine instance navigating to
the list of GCE images you can see that
it already have two separate images one
for the front end and one for the back
end okay before we step through
terraform config file let's show you how
to use terraform plan to see what
resources terraform will create in this
case we don't have any of our
infrastructure provisioned and as you
can see terraformers expect new versions
set of new resources with zero changes
in Co deletions when we're happy with
what we expect terraform to do we can
then run terraform apply performant the
actual infrastructure provisioning
well--that's provisioning let's walk
through that configuration file this
first section of file contains the GCP
project parameters i haven't specified a
service account key in this example
because I'm running terraform on a
compute engine instance and terraform is
smart enough to pull credentials from
the metadata service next you see I have
a resource specifying my back-end GCE
virtual machine instance including the
name zone location in machine type
here's the snippet where I've specified
that I want this instance to use the
back-end image built with Packer
skipping down to the stanza for our
front-end VM instances you can see that
I've specified the other Packer image
but we want three of these instances so
we need to set it to count to three I'm
also provisioning a GC load balancer
using a target pool in forwarding rule
using the output parameter I can tell
terraform to print out the load
balancers virtual IP address when it's
completed provisioning all of our
resources slipping back to our other
terminal you can see the terraform has
indeed finished provisioning our
resources and here's the front end IP
let's put that IP address into our
browser and see what happens
it works awesome okay well let's go
ahead and delete all of these resources
we can easily do that with terraform
destroy so that wraps up the demo well
we only showed you a subset of GCC
services in the demo there's enough I
think for you to get started with the
others
so Patti how do users get start to the
terraform simple enough Dana just go to
terraform daddy-o
check out the docs and keep track of our
github repository we're constantly
adding new GCP resources to terraform
this has been fun Dana and I've really
enjoyed working with you on terraform
thanks Patti I've enjoyed working with
you too
and I'm looking forward to adding new
resources and features over time thanks
to all of you for watching us today we
hope to give terraform and GCP a try and
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
so you can catch the next video in the
Hashi club series thanks for watching
make sure to check out some other videos
in this series as well as the playlists
and don't forget to subscribe